Sammy nominated rapper Remy Ma energy
[Applause]
oh it's too bad that you need your mom's
lap right now because I am a mom and I
want you on my lap so badly and you can
keep sucking your thumb because I did
until I was nine years old you're
nervous all right Mary oh my gosh
surprise me Mama come on come sit on my
lap
[Applause]
um
what's it like to be best friends with
Mary oh Mary she's Abby you know you
meet somebody like you um aspire to meet
somebody and you look up to somebody and
then you meet them and you just
sometimes in this industry you meet them
and they're not really what you
envisioned them to be
not only is she everything that I
thought she would be like she's like
past that like she's sir
[Applause]
real down to earth I would say probably
eight out of ten times we see each other
we end up crying yeah somehow some way
like she but she has that because it's
so real it's so authentic and it's
genuine you feel it like you feel her
you don't just see her you feel her and
I think what she's doing in her Legacy
and I don't even know if she's aware of
how many people that she touched with my
daughter my daughter's four years old
I can't I don't even know how she like
latched on somewhere like that one day
she has this song called amazing and she
keeps playing the song over and I'm like
how do you know that song she's like
yeah that Spirit first she thought it
was me I'm not gonna lie I let the LIE
go on for about two months Michael she
thinks Mary J blotches me like whatever
so then she realized she's like that's
Mary J Blige when she first met her like
she's like literally she goes but can we
call Mary J Blige today like like she
that's my best friend like we're
backstage and kids as we now know don't
lie no they just they have no filter
very very honest but just to show the
generational impact that she's had from
and and I think sometimes we need to
hear that as human beings like you you
start to feel like all right well I made
my Mark I did whatever and she just
keeps going like this like literally I'm
reading her the book backstage and it's
a part in the book that says um the the
Mary was being told no yes because a lot
of times when people tell you you can't
I know it's because they have small
dreams and she goes not me I have big
dreams
I'm like you know those are the things
that that you need to install into the
youth so I love it I love you know let
me ask you two women do you think that
there has been a conscientious probably
supported by someone like you if you
um four young girls like do you think
that they
that we have given enough
yeses in certain ways as women that
younger girls do believe in themselves a
little bit more
I think the yes is when people see us as
celebrities go through hell
on television like like in
they see us it's public our divorce is
public God Falls are public our
embarrassment's the public and then they
see us come through
that's the yes that's that's the yes you
can that let's say you can if you I if I
could hear what you can do I love that
so much as someone who has spent my
whole life uh having to learn in front
of people and I do think that
you know
we I think we're
able to live up to the promise of the
book that you wrote honestly I think we
are living in a day and age where women
are and young girls are truly fighting
for their rights and their voices to be
heard and fighting in a way where they
believe in themselves and they're trying
to take care of one another so I believe
that this is you know always an
important and necessary message for
young girls and parents for how we
figure out how to guide and Lead
[Music]
foreign